hey everybody Doug Walker here so this
week we did not record our first viewing
of clock stoppers we didn't have that
much to say anyway we can do we wind up
but the ones going forward we will and
the real thoughts this week because I'm
busy editing Suicide Squad ahead of time
from the big screening what we didn't
have time to film one so what we're
doing is that we're actually taking the
end of our first viewing of Fantastic
Four fan for stick and putting that on
because Rob specifically goes on so long
talking about how much he hates the
movie that he actually at one point even
says just make this the real thought so
that's pretty much what I'm doing so
don't worry we'll get back to the the
first viewing of the real thoughts
afterwards but for now we're just gonna
show you just the ravings right after we
saw this movie and I think it's his
anger at this film at the purest I don't
think you can get a angrier than this so
uh enjoy what a bait-and-switch because
I thought at first I'm like you know
what this is not gonna be as bad as
everybody was making that to me I'm like
okay it's a little dull but I'm like
this is semi-competent I'm like okay
they're trying to take a little more
seriously and just nothing yeah nothing
came on half a bunch of nothing you know
and it's like the movie itself is so
embarrassed to be fantastic for that
they could never verbally say it out
loud until the very you know they didn't
say it's right the movie saying it
doesn't even open up with you are
watching the Fantastic Four they wait
till the end to show you the title cuz
it's like we we can't even say it
where were that a shame you know what
sucks all of this yeah but the first
half of the movie where they weren't
doing jack shit was still the better
half yeah they still didn't fucking do
anything the most we got was a montage
hey here's what we've been doing for a
past year why don't you fucking show us
like the little video screen is nice why
don't you fucking show us that what the
fuck and then and then at the end that
that climax is completely
incomprehensible you still can't take
doom release seriously you know what you
got to just fuck him run with doom man
because you're never gonna take it
seriously it's like either have him
running his bullshit country or don't
bother at all because fucking paper
mache head like is not where
good for me you know and with that's too
fantastic for remakes now or you know
reboots whatever you want to call them
where they don't fight crime they cause
more trouble than they fix I mean they
caused all of these and there's nothing
really that fantastic about the Huff no
it just
they have no chemistry with each other I
will say this at least they don't have
bad chemistry it's just no chemistry
I've seen movies where they literally a
bad chemistry it's like I don't believe
that you guys would even like go to the
catering table at the same time in
between takes it's how much you fuckin
hate each other well you know it's not
like that but they still have zero
chemistry it's just more like just like
after their different like yeah later
you know with with the first one is bad
and I don't believe that you know fuck
the interracially I don't care about
that there's interracial couples and and
I just they didn't act like brother and
sister
I just didn't believe that they were
related with the Furze oh they're gonna
do that sort of thing you'd better make
me believe that there at least related I
have to whatever they said father and
sister I'm like oh yeah they're relate
like I completely forgot there's any
connection to you know at all I forgot
that he was so did I like he never
talked to her like a daughter sometimes
when he talks to a Johnny Storm
I forget that he's his father knows if
they had the one scene with the car okay
that was like father and son but nobody
knows because we needed to have takes
that went on for 30 minutes when they
were just typing shit or they would say
in light of jelly oh my god this reminds
it's like fucking unbreakable man where
you have these like long conversation
scenes that go on for 40 minutes because
they just don't cut in between takes in
between lines of dialogue so they'll say
something and just hold on their face
for an extra threesome with Shyamalan
also show off I can do this in one shot
with this there was anything they just
included like all the dialogue yeah and
man there's just at least with the first
one I remember kind of how lame and
silly and bad they were remember think
about these guys who are you playing
about problems
like Avengers two or something but this
climax literally what the Avengers ate
digested shit out and then basically
buried into the ground and then you dug
up one little petrified remains were
left of those turds that doesn't even
come close to describing this climax
like this was the corn in the Avengers
two's climaxes shit you know like that
just I'm sorry like that bothers me most
so it's like well at least maybe we'll
get some eye candy
you couldn't fucking see anything what
you could see was just this jumbled CGI
mess that's not even like listen the
avengers like movies and and darkening
like a lot of these they use a lot of
cgi I don't care that CGI it's just I
can't even tell what the fuck I'm
looking at like transformers makes more
sense when it comes to their climaxes
than this like I can still kind of make
out what's going on in a Michael Bay
movie this was worse than that what I
feel like if that guy has that much
power to move all these rocks and
everything like there they are see
Jesse's giant rock hands come up they be
gone dead like that Viet why is this
taking so long
hit me with a rock yeah I just like that
was like the things like I was like I
guess it's very thing but I'm just like
really just hit him with a rock like why
not whistling just and Susan I can make
myself invisible will this come in handy
ever no not really
does she ever you try to her
invisibility even in the original you
wasn't the first one with power yeah she
used the shell op even though the first
one she does go invisible to get the
drop on people and save people and stuff
like that it's like yeah she never uses
her invisibility in this you know what
thinking back just after seeing wanted
and I wanted to like it from the first
20 minutes like I remember like I hope
like more like okay this isn't perfect
but the stronger start then I thought it
was gonna be and I want to like this
maybe it will get better as it goes
along
no it just got worse and worse and worse
what I really like my own thoughts right
now ya know what I remember most is that
first is that first like 20 minutes I
maybe even half hour I kind of remember
them as kids playing the stuff together
and everything and it's like it was
still kind of lame but it's like I'm
like I just don't remember anything I
kind of remember what the thing looks
like I remember the montage just goes
like that's cool can we see more of them
doing their super but that was it bad
balloon you don't even like all the cool
stuff is on video why are we watching
that on video why don't you see the test
why don't you mean what's your side
having good people at Texas the story
goes that Fox saw the original cut and
was like fuck this and I have no idea
cuz I am assuming we watched the Fox cut
I have no idea of tranqs cuts any better
it could be just as awful just in
different ways but this did feel like
two separate movies I felt like after
they got their superpowers we dumped
into some other film that was its own
separate origin story this was like two
different origin stories if you add them
as kids like growing up to the point
where they get the surprise and then the
new origin story starts after they get
the superpowers and none was
particularly interesting but I stuffed
up the first was better I still don't
get why like the whole like oh she's got
a romance kind of with Von Doom and now
he's pissed off anywhere I guess so and
II grew that I'm gonna beat you up read
because you had a romance but you never
did stupid yet like all these things
don't think about that they did that I
forgot about like oh my god they did
that in the first crappy remake and it's
like yeah that was actually done better
there it cuz at least I can remember it
at least I'm like oh there was like he
was proposing to her looking over the
earth and stuff like that it's like I
remember visually cyber goin West don't
was stupid but it was there it was
memorable they just removed it all
together so I'm like well I can't say it
was stupid but there was nothing else
there yeah you removed like kind of what
makes the Fantastic Four just fantastic
yeah instead there's just four we have
four but no fantastic gritty you're just
like guess it number four it's like
looking at the number four it's like
well yeah that's for fucking Christopher
Nolan man I feel everything comes back
we have our problems with Dark Knight
Rises but I still feel those films from
beginning to end we're at least a
complete trilogy didn't end perfectly
but unlike
Batman Forever compared to Batman
Returns into like I felt like okay this
is a complete set and the Dark Knight is
an amazing movie it's still it's like in
my top five comment of movies of all
time I thought Batman Begins was really
solid and there are parts of Dark Knight
I like I'm like okay Dark Knight Rises
yeah that wrap up altogether but I feel
like they've been trying so fucking hard
since it won't work the dark guy it's
got to work here and it's like yeah but
Christopher Nolan like lover hate
everything he does fucking knew what he
was doing with Dark Knight like it may
not be 100% perfect there's little tiny
things that I would fix it he fucking
nailed it with that one and everybody
just thinks well we can just do Dark
Knight again but it's starting to get to
the point where I'm just like listen
that maybe like the for lack of a better
word the Citizen Kane of like dark
gritty superhero movies are the
Schindler's List of super you're just
not gonna be able to do it again it's
just a fucking like saying okay that
worked once we're gonna have to try to
do our own thing and not fuckin copy the
Dark Knight which is what I feel like so
many of these are doing well but they're
like anyone honestly just not marble MCU
right now marble that's the sad part as
Marvel is the only one who's nailed it
with daredevil yeah which is in Jessica
Jones yeah or you know what okay you
know what no okay fucking DC this I'll
give do you see this I thought they did
the first two seasons of arrow
I thought they fucking nailed it like
four it's not exactly like what it is
very different a seeds TV with their
first now the seasons of era after that
or not as good but those first two
seasons I'm like okay you nailed it with
that it's not it's a slightly little
goofier than Dark Knight but I think you
nailed that kind of TOEIC this guy's
gonna be naso and beat the shit out of
people and kill people and he's gonna be
a billionaire and let it
I hear flash and Supergirl adjusted it's
a culturally and it's a fairly great and
I'm just like working about give credit
that it's not to me if arrow is like
Dark Knight then the flash to be is like
spider-man so it's a goofier universe
and then it's girls like super girls
like fucking Richard Donner hyper man
yeah which I liked and I could take it
just it's like a little more serious I
think than the Richard Donner Superman
and I really like it so it's like they
have some concept of what they're doing
there even if they're going up and down
with it it's not all good but you know
apparently Marvel's Iron Fist sucks so
it's like they're not infallible either
I fucking Fox like fuck but one and I
like the Fantastic Four that's what
pisses me off this is gonna be a real
thoughts as well like Fantastic Four I
read as a kid like now was one of those
that I read really as a younger kid like
it was one of those like you kind of
grow out of it a little because it
always was kind of goofy but the old I
used to have the old Fantastic Four
comics I had this big Marvel collection
it was this book that had a number of
the first issues and like maybe a few
story arts after that and like how do
you take something that was just fun and
colorful and its own thing and just
twice fuck it up at least what the
spider-man films spider-man 1 is OK
spider-man 2 is a really solid movie
spider-man 3 sucked in with the reboot
I'm like spider-man woman was okay in
spider-man 2 romance was good who woulda
guessed that and then the rest of the
movie said but at least you went pieces
they're fantastic ports agree em they're
jack shit yet and this was the second
remount the second reboot your fuck it
seen or done it to Marvel I'm watching
this I'm thinking to myself okay this
like Sony but Logan Logan was amazing
but we're done with Fantastic Four uh
you know I'm watching I'm thinking
myself oh you know okay like this first
20 minutes like you said isn't it's a
great that's probably not fantastic for
but at least it's interesting enough and
just do the whole time of watching I'm
saying well this but this isn't as bad
as the you know the remake or the last
more Silver Surfer anything and it's
just like man yeah just with the total
lack of anything happening I'm like it
does kind of become worse because at
least I remember that first one I just
so barely remember anything the first
okay it's the Mortal Kombat annihilation
thing I remember that film because it's
so awful much more than I do the first
one and it's a mega fantastic but the
first one is so goofy awful bad then I
remember bored
so gritty boring bad that I yeah about
the first 20 minutes in that middle
montage it's all I remember yeah yep
we're done
I just fucking so yeah pretty bad not
not a good film uh would you say it's
worse than the first one that what do I
even call that one the 90s why I think
was in the 90s or 2000s what do you even
call it they're just you can't see the
bad one the Chris Evans one yeah Captain
America Fantastic Four okay yeah is this
worse than the Chris Evans Fantastic
Four would you say oh man it's like the
apples and oranges of Shipton yeah it
really is
I appreciated trying to take it more
seriously early on in this way more than
in the other film where it was just so
goofy that it was obnoxious but I can't
remember this movie and I at least
remember I remember I remember some of
the action but the problem is if you
want to take it seriously you have to
have a payoff you have to Dark Knight it
and like just know how to execute it
properly and they didn't so the other
one is kind of worse and how goofy it is
like you can't take any of that
seriously but I sure as hell remember it
more you all know what you want - why -
and I'll give it is probably bothered me
a little less just because I feel like
this being the second time around I'm
like no no you should have gotten your
share
yeah you know what the first this one
took snow chances it didn't take one
damn chance you know if casting a black
guy is the Human Torch is your big
chance you know your big risk is that I
must be the character is breaking he's
gonna be a poorly written character like
that's gonna be the only interesting
thing about him is that he's black and
that was like him street racing and like
the fact that there were some inner
racial like that was the most
interesting thing that they wrote
nothing else interesting about those
three no like nothing and it didn't you
know what bothers me
it did not inform if you're going to be
like okay we're gonna change the race of
this character and this bugs the shit
out of me if you're gonna change the
race of this character make them an
interracial family that's fine does it
inform anything they do
is there anything sort of special that
they get out of that like you know
growing up in an interracial family we
had to deal with a lot of shit or you
know we had to learn how to get along
because it was tough or people looked at
us funny or and it doesn't inform
anything in the fucking movie that
there'd be like we can apply this to
fighting as superheroes are getting
through this challenge fucking zero
nothing you did it just to get a rise
out of people just to be like hey we did
this look at a movie and like you know
of course the fucking racist idiots or
just a cure major he's black while
everybody else is just like no we have
to defend this because he's black and
the reality is it didn't mean jack shit
happy for me if you do something like
that doesn't always have to have an
impact as long as it represents the
character well like Billy Dee Williams
is okay would be a cool be fucking
Williams and Batman with a thousand
times more interesting than this he
would be an interesting to face you know
so that's why it's like not what these
people are poisoning us with and bad um
I think he has like two lines I know
what I was going to say the last thing I
have to make it about that specific to
make a major change like that then you
have to make sure you have some well
written characters you're right like
Billy Dee Williams is not like we knew
everything but the acting the way his
character was and it wasn't way
portrayed it's you didn't think about
the change in race because it was a good
character in this one you think about
the change in race because like this is
not a good cuz it's nothing else to
think about we don't get anything else
out of this are you going to least use
the racial thing to try to like milk
something out of this and nothing so it
family
every single level and all three of them
seem like perfectly decent actors so
it's not like I'm soon there going like
oh he's bad knows he doesn't miss cast
when he smiled and was trying to be a
jackass when the script would let him I
would I would be like okay like I could
see how he could be a good Human Torch
I thought Susan storms she was fine in
cases she had like focus in her eyes
like I could see her being a scientist I
could see Danny torch her daddy storm
you know being the serious talent but
the script just gave them no lines to
chew on I much rather have something
take a risk and fail than something
played safe bland
not interesting all the way through
because at least the failure will leave
an impact I will say the first movie
left more than impact yeah remember how
bad yeah I and I just all I remember
from this is just sheer disappointment
yeah just a total nothing happening and
why watch them much rather watch you
know the room then you know a blank
screen you know so yeah that's that's
our thoughts on it and shut this bottle
of TV the Fantastic Four there are
definitely four but not fantastic
definitely not fantastic so therefore
these films no no there's more though
there are three films no no Corman which
is sadly the best at least go fight
crime it looks like the Fantastic Four
yeah so um we have that's about it and
maybe we'll see you next time bye
you